**Susan Daniels**: Welcome back, I hope you stretch your legs got something that has a refreshment and you're ready to dig back and we're going to finish wrapping up on the second segment of the afternoon session of day three and this video.
**Susan Daniels**: The next thing that we're good we just talked about different arm contingency plans and fallback plans and workaround plans and secondary risks and now we're going to talk about what kind of risk response strategies we have available to us as project managers and here is an excellent.
**Susan Daniels**: Video to help explain it.
**Susan Daniels**: Once you've analyzed your project risks and determined which ones, have the highest risk rating the next logical step is to plan your risk responses.
**Susan Daniels**: That way, if a risk becomes an issue you'll have a plan to address it will start with threats, this is a description of each risk response.
**Susan Daniels**: And an example that goes along with it escalate would be the appropriate response if you determine that the threat is outside of the scope of the project and exceeds your authority as a project manager.
**Susan Daniels**: For example, you notify the p mo that a cease and desist order has been received, to stop project work avoid is when you change the project management plan through integrated change control to totally eliminate the threat.
**Susan Daniels**: For example, removing a feature from the scope or extending the schedule baseline to meet a due date transfer mean shifting the impact with third party, who is now going to be responsible for the response.
**Susan Daniels**: This usually happens when we have a cost related risk and in contracts, for example, purchasing insurance or a warranty.
**Susan Daniels**: When you mitigate you reduce the probability and or the impact, so it falls within an acceptable threshold an example would be negotiating with a backup supplier for more materials.
**Susan Daniels**: or interviewing candidates for potential job openings before you need them or also following the weather report.
**Susan Daniels**: And finally accept means determining not to change the course of action, this could be passive where no action is taken.
**Susan Daniels**: or where we use a pre determined amount of contingency reserves to accept the risk, for example, putting funds into the contingency reserve to pay for the impact of a risk event.
**Susan Daniels**: Just as we have risk responses for threats, we also have them for opportunities escalate is when you determine that the opportunity is outside the scope of your project and it exceeds your authority as the project manager.
**Susan Daniels**: For example, you notify the that a vendor has offered you have volume discount.
**Susan Daniels**: exploit means changing the project management plan through integrated change control to eliminate the uncertainty and make it happen, for example, adding a feature to the scope baseline.
**Susan Daniels**: To potentially guarantee having the best product on the market, when you share you allocate some or all of the impact to a third party, who is better able to capture the opportunity for the benefit of the product.
**Susan Daniels**: This usually happens with joint ventures and contracts, so I have a question about this one, if this is such a good opportunity.
**Susan Daniels**: Why would we want to share the opportunity with anyone else, why wouldn't we take full advantage of it ourselves.
**Susan Daniels**: Maybe your organization or your team doesn't have the necessary skill sets or you don't have the funding to make it happen.
**Susan Daniels**: So a partnership might be the only way that you could pursue the opportunity also when you share on the opportunity side, you may be transferring on the threat side as well.
**Susan Daniels**: If you recall that sensitivity analysis or tornado diagram where we had both threats and opportunities related to a single risk.
**Susan Daniels**: Sharing opportunities and transferring threats, could be a great combined strategy for this situation.
**Susan Daniels**: OK now we'll explore the risk response enhance, which means maximizing the probability and impact.
**Susan Daniels**: For example, adding more resources to an activity, so that it finishes early and, finally, just as we did with threats we have except.
**Susan Daniels**: When you accept you're willing to take advantage of an opportunity, but you aren't actively pursuing it so let's say we have very experienced staff, and we know they'll quickly create a high quality deliverable.
**Susan Daniels**: But we won't necessarily give them additional resources or training to make sure it happens.
When planning risks, we do everything we can to anticipate risk events that can impact the project.
When a negative risk is only a possibility, we call it a threat when that threat actually happens, we call it an issue let's visit this risk issue and assess the situation.
The project manager is reading the paper and says, well, it looks like we're getting some negative media attention.
We knew this was a possibility and i'd like to handle it as quickly as possible, what should we do first.
Can you determine if there are any clues in the statement that would tell us whether this is unknown unknown or an unknown unknown.
Maybe you recognize this as a known unknown, we know this because the project manager said we knew this was a possibility that's our clue.
So if we identify the possibility of this risk during planning, what do you think we should do next, if you need a hint i'll ask you this question.
Is this risk in the risk register, what do you think if you said yes, you are correct any risks that we identified during risk planning should be in that risk register so we'll refer to that document.
It should contain information about our planned risk response, as well as the risk owner who should be the person implementing the response.
What about any costs associated with this risk with a project manager have the authority to spend the money.
If you recall any significant risks that are identified during planning will likely also have funding associated with them.
it's part of the contingency reserve and it's built into the cost baseline the project manager does have the authority to spend this money in response to the risk.
Now let's explore a different situation, a terrible storm has occurred, and the project manager says what terrible luck, we never see this type of damaging whether.
This is unheard of, so of course we didn't plan for it, what do we do first, can you determine if there are any clues in a statement that would tell us whether this is unknown unknown or an unknown unknown.
Maybe recognize that this is an unknown unknown, we know this because the project manager said we didn't plan for it that's our clue.
So if we didn't identify the possibility of this risk during planning, what do you think we should do next, is this risk in the risk register, if you said no you're correct.
What about any costs associated with this risk, the project manager doesn't have the authority to spend money and response to this risk.
They must get funding from management reserves one more thing if the risk isn't documented in the risk register, are there any other project documents that we might be able to refer.
**Susan Daniels**: hi Okay, so that was an explanation of what was going on in the arm the different risk responses that we can have.
**Susan Daniels**: Good has questions that can arise out of that give you different scenarios and you would first identify it as a threat or an opportunity.
**Susan Daniels**: Then you would have to decide from whether it was a threat or an opportunity which would be most applicable.
**Susan Daniels**: If you'll notice that they kind of parallels to each other right, you can escalate it to leadership, you can either avoid it completely if it's negative or exploited, make it happen okay.
**Susan Daniels**: transfer it if it's bad like paying the insurance company to take the risk or you can go find a partner to make sure you can take advantage of the opportunity, you may have to share it but either way there's someone else involved.
**Susan Daniels**: and mitigating enhance or just the opposites of each other, much like avoid and exploit mitigate means minimize the impact of minimize the probability enhanced means improve the probability improve the impact.
**Susan Daniels**: I do want to go back to a couple of questions we had in the chat one of them was regarding Okay, we got it to the airport Okay, then what well we're not in workaround mode at that point, our fallback plans are generally holistic and i'm require us looking at it for end to end so are.
**Susan Daniels**: Our fallback plans are well developed so once it got to the airport, we knew what we were going to do next right we knew where the plane is going to go.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, who we were going to book through, and you know who was going to pick it up from the airport we basically you create a robust fallback plan and a robust yeah fallback plan.
**Susan Daniels**: Much like a contingency plan, there was another question in the chat that came through about wouldn't this be the vendors responsibility to do the transportation.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, in this scenario, I was, I was assuming that the vendor was only going to manufacturer the part in that they didn't take any transport accountability, it was on us to get the park from one place to the other.
**Susan Daniels**: You could contract for them to be responsible and manage that risk, but I, for my purposes avila's teaching and illustration, we had the responsibility of managing the risk.
**Susan Daniels**: I hope that answered the two questions that were there before okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so um.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so this is our summary slide that the talk about determine and implement risk responses right study these you need to.
**Susan Daniels**: create a set of each of these guidelines there's sort of like a desktop reference, but we can get a lot of questions out of it okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Now we're changing gears okay we're going to move into execute and deliver business value that tells us we're definitely into kind of loot leaving the planning component of.
**Susan Daniels**: The work right and now we're getting into the execution execute the project to deliver value hey.
**Susan Daniels**: Nothing specific because we're doing everything to execute right we we bring everything to the table, so instead of just loading it all onto this slide they just said nothing specific because we use everything to deliver value.
**Susan Daniels**: Delivering value is the goal Okay, then it's been identified in the beginning, through the Charter what the objectives are and why they funded the project at the first place right what they off with the business value is for this project.
**Susan Daniels**: Keeping that in mind, and making that if you are familiar with the North star when you navigate it never changes, it is the one star in the heavens that people can navigate off of well the definition of the business value that your projects trying to deliver is what you on lead torch.
**Susan Daniels**: And it's your job to continuously champion and communicate that vision okay.
**Susan Daniels**: It is up to you to be that can do will do let's get it done champion of your project.
**Susan Daniels**: People will rally to your project if you're enthusiastic about it, if they see what the value is for the whole company right what's in it for them, and if you're high energy and you're got high motivation Okay, then people will resonate that they will imitate that okay.
**Susan Daniels**: um what's in it for them is really the way that you get people on board to see, and if it's nothing personal, then they need to understand their job is part of this company.
**Susan Daniels**: And what's the benefit to the whole company what's the business value of doing this and how is the company dependent on them to see this be successful.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm commit to and be accountable for striving towards that vision, this is kind of pmi speak for be the champion okay if you're given a project you can't be.
**Susan Daniels**: You know kind of neutral about it and kind of just our eye on David don you know you've got to when you are the project manager, which we are.
**Susan Daniels**: kind of internal discussions project leader Okay, then you've got to get a group of people to work together towards a common vision and you've got to be committed to that vision if you're going to get them to commit.
**Susan Daniels**: So when we're talking about what is the business value well business value comes in a variety of manifestations, or it comes to to light and a lot of different ways.
**Susan Daniels**: it's not just the money it's not just the financial game Okay, sometimes it's getting into new market shares are bringing in new customers, the whole project is about trying to expand the presence of your organization in the market.
**Susan Daniels**: You may have projects around implementing new technology, you don't have to be in the information technology division to be able to implement technology okay.
**Susan Daniels**: You need to understand how they plan which will cover an agile, but you also need to understand you may put in new phone systems, you may be.
**Susan Daniels**: Leading some upgrades in software, there are all kinds of technology improvements, the project managers can do that, then you don't have to be a coder in a developer to lead technology projects.
**Susan Daniels**: Now I do want to draw your attention to this one over here social.
**Susan Daniels**: Some projects but we'll touch on improvement first improvements are kind of fix what's broken kind of projects okay or compliance projects fix what's broken get things done, we have to get done to stay in compliance right.
**Susan Daniels**: But that's business value, but this one has nothing to do with finances okay and it's not going to necessarily land, a new product in the market it's when a company.
**Susan Daniels**: Does a project simply for brand value or how it's being positioned in the market, what is its corporate reputation okay that's what it's talking about.
**Susan Daniels**: When you do projects relative to starting a foundation right for your company and i'm overseeing the grant process right building and designing a grant process and handing it off.
**Susan Daniels**: To a team that would be for social order social good um again brand value so not all projects about it or return on investment that's financial Okay, there are vast array of ways that projects can deliver value to their to their internal and external customers.
**Susan Daniels**: Give me a moment I want to read something that's on my upper screen.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay um so.
**Susan Daniels**: Your role is to continuously evaluate, am I, giving the business what they need, and where we're going with this slide is.
**Susan Daniels**: Some projects take a long time to get done right and where we started at the beginning of the year and we wrote the Charter and we define success build our plan and we're executing.
**Susan Daniels**: it's up to you to kind of stay in tune with him what i'm building and delivering still with the company needs okay.
**Susan Daniels**: And you have to ask that difficult question on a somewhat regular basis, are you offering your project up to be adapted and changed.
**Susan Daniels**: yeah in a way, you are but it shows business acumen to recognize that the business is shifting and moving and responding to the market and the market is always changing.
**Susan Daniels**: So, at a certain cadence like it, each one of your face gates right, you may want to ask these are the objectives, this project is trying to achieve.
**Susan Daniels**: and ask the governance board is this still in alignment with the business strategy and.
**Susan Daniels**: You know that kind of gives them permission to evaluate their investment and go yeah definitely keep going yeah yeah no problem here or well.
**Susan Daniels**: I think we're still in alignment now but that's a good question let's look at that by the time we meet again right so they're kind of like you sensitize them.
**Susan Daniels**: This is for traditional plan based.
**Susan Daniels**: Trying to examine business value and what they want this is done, almost in real time every iteration in agile and agile is extremely good.
**Susan Daniels**: At staying in sync with what the business needs now okay and that's why they work on such short horizon lines they work on the highest priority feature capability.
**Susan Daniels**: produce it and ask them do you like what we delivered you now what's the next most important thing Okay, and you keep looking at re prioritizing and prioritizing The next thing that's built.
**Susan Daniels**: There is when you think of agile agile whole mindset is about delivering business value as as quickly as possible.
**Susan Daniels**: The learning comes from traditional plan based you as a project manager need to be the one that makes sure.
**Susan Daniels**: That your project is delivering what they need not what they asked for because you're very much giving them what they asked for, but you have to be more sophisticated have more business acumen and ask them i'm delivering what you asked for is that still what you need, am I, making sense.
**Susan Daniels**: This looking at the feedback great.
**Susan Daniels**: Changing subjects, again, I told you this afternoon sort of popcorn array of topics we're going to introduce now.
**Susan Daniels**: Managing communications and there's quite a few slides relative to managing communications just on the whole, and then we're going to focus more on stakeholder engagement, the kind of the reason we do.
**Susan Daniels**: The communication plan, but there is some groundwork to lay in just managing communications before we focus on stakeholders specifically.
**Susan Daniels**: we're going to look at this understand and practice, the sender receiver model we're gonna actually look at the model and i'm going to talk to you about key aspects of it when we get there okay um.
**Susan Daniels**: But you can't be surprised that we're going to have to put together a communication plan right.
**Susan Daniels**: Project communications Oh, my goodness, if we're not negotiating, which is a form of communication, we are communicating internally externally ups.
**Susan Daniels**: up the arm the hierarchy of the project, the organization, as well as you know, maybe to some of the people that are not of the same peer group, as we are, but we are communicating omni directional with in an organization.
**Susan Daniels**: There are different tones and style some of our communications are official summer unofficial it's just understand that communication skills for a project manager right up there at the top of the list with negotiation and conflict management right we communicate almost all day long.
**Susan Daniels**: So we have to put together a communication management plan.
**Susan Daniels**: And this is just an example, this is not the way to do it Okay, but it just simply says, you need to know what are you going to be communicating I have certain performance reports I have to communicate.
**Susan Daniels**: I okay right and I have different channels that i'm going to communicate through.
**Susan Daniels**: And I have to know where i'm going to store the files and I need to know who's responsible for creating these communications we don't have to create every one of our own communications, you can delegate, some of them to TEAM members to be able to do first drafts.
**Susan Daniels**: oftentimes, you will have subject matter experts that will be led to your project.
**Susan Daniels**: And they think what you do is really cool and they want to grow up and be what you are, which is a project manager, because they are bored out of their skull doing their.
**Susan Daniels**: Operations work and they want to know how to get into what you do so, you can mentor and coach these people, by giving them development opportunities.
**Susan Daniels**: And one of the best ways I did it was to ask them to help me with some of my performance reports I.
**Susan Daniels**: asked them to gather the data and analyze it and give me their first draft, based upon the information that was provided now depending on where they were in their development sometimes it took a lot of rework sometimes not so much right, but the idea is you can.
**Susan Daniels**: delegate some aspects of your communications right and but ultimately you're responsible for review and approval of everything that goes out.
**Susan Daniels**: Now you communication plan and this doesn't show it, but the way I organize my communication plan was first column what reports.
**Susan Daniels**: Where I was I going to create on a regular basis, I had my schedule, I had my budget I had my risk register, you see where i'm going.
**Susan Daniels**: I had my racy who's doing what right and what's their role um I had different documents that I continuously updated my procurement plan update right I don't report on all my requirements, so I will list in the first column what I was going to create and distribute.
**Susan Daniels**: In the second column I would list who's going to give me information for that who am I going to get my information from Okay, and then the next column how often would I get it right.
**Susan Daniels**: And when I said, who i'd also have their contact information underneath that so and how often like was it by the 30th of the month, was it by the first of the month, when would they give this to me.
**Susan Daniels**: Then I would talk about what Doc, then I would have who was in my distribution list for this document right who all gets a copy or who gets administrative access to that folder out on the cloud, and I would have my list of those people.
**Susan Daniels**: And then I would have a column for feedback.
**Susan Daniels**: Because, you will get feedback on what you distribute so that I could kind of have a continuous lessons learned section going for my communications.
**Susan Daniels**: Your communication plan okay is really how are you what are you going to communicate how you're going to get the information, who you're going to give it to you would also have where is it going to be stored what folder what location, the exact mapping right to that folder.
**Susan Daniels**: And I would then just take that information and kind of attach it to it's an excel spreadsheet.
**Susan Daniels**: And I will just attach it to a word document saying my communication management plan, please review revise and return for common okay I created I would mock it up.
**Susan Daniels**: And then see what my leadership thought it's not hard to write didn't take me more than an hour to, to put it together Max sometimes my distribution list took longer to develop than anything else.
**Susan Daniels**: And that's the basis of a communication plan.
**Susan Daniels**: stakeholder okay I wouldn't use anything like key stakeholders, I would literally have you know my whole email distribution list that I could copy and paste right into my email so that.
**Susan Daniels**: It was available in case I was working somewhere where I didn't have access to automatically saved distributions some.
**Susan Daniels**: Some communication platforms allow you to create distribution list and save them.
**Susan Daniels**: it's a good thing you don't know how to do that learn how to create distribution lists and save them in your communication tool.
**Susan Daniels**: But in case I was working remotely couldn't get access to that I can always open up my communication plan and copy and paste that distribution list right into the into the tool, I was using wherever I logged into.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: I like this slide it gives you an idea of other things, to take into consideration other columns you may want to build into your communication plan, I was just giving you the must haves you know, like the essential elements of a communication plan.
**Susan Daniels**: let's see i'm going to scan it with you.
**Susan Daniels**: um now it's interesting says time and budget allocation some communications may require production costs okay.
**Susan Daniels**: um one of the projects that I worked on was to develop the annual board report for them, on the annual report for the Board of Directors that was early in my career, I used to do a lot of board communications and we were produced this worldly glossy high end.
**Susan Daniels**: really nice document almost bragging rights sort of quality document for our C suite who would then presented to the board and then this was kind of get tossed around and certain on.
**Susan Daniels**: meetings that they would be in to kind of say i'm on the board of this or this is how we're doing um so there was production costs involved in my communication plan right for producing that.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, oh I love this glossary of common terminology whoa how many of you out there don't really have to answer this but think inside your head.
**Susan Daniels**: Have you ever worked on a project, and there is so many acronyms Oh, my goodness, you don't even understand what how these people are talking to each other, it is like.
**Susan Daniels**: alphabet soup flying back and forth right well you kind of need a decoder right, so this decoder can be your glossary of terminology.
**Susan Daniels**: which can really help your subject matter experts that you're bringing in who sit in these meetings and watch people talking acronyms and they're there to help one one aspect, this is yeah so it's very helpful.
**Susan Daniels**: To build a terminology or an acronym list okay oh yeah you military folk.
**Susan Daniels**: You blow me away, sometimes with all of your your your acronyms So yes, i'm sure many of you in the United States military understand this, but i'm sure there's other business domains that use a lot of acronyms and very term very specific terms.
**Susan Daniels**: On this is also helpful if you have a contract and there's very specific terms on that contract that you want to make sure everybody's got the same understanding.
**Susan Daniels**: But, as you say, oh here's another one constraints due to regulation or policies, not everybody gets copied on all the information in your project communications.
**Susan Daniels**: Not everybody's going to get to see the budget Okay, not everybody gets to see how well the budget is literally spending right and where the spend is that all they get to see is on plan you know.
**Susan Daniels**: Are within tolerances in that kind of generic phrase you get to use, because you negotiated tolerances right okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so this is a, this is a cool slide so communication requirements analysis fairy big words for just making sure you're meeting your stakeholders expectations it's really what it's about.
**Susan Daniels**: So you've got your templates for your performance reports yay that them built.
**Susan Daniels**: You have built your distribution list you move forward in your execution and you're going to distribute your first round of performance reports Oh, by the way, you've already had been pre approved okay as.
**Susan Daniels**: templates and mock ups of your communication your performance reports go up in your communication plan hey, this is the way i'm going to communicate the schedule.
**Susan Daniels**: milestone summary Gantt chart all details, you know you give up whatever model you think you're going to use with them, you have your budget mock approved, you have your.
**Susan Daniels**: Risk register approved know your risk monitoring and report.
**Susan Daniels**: You got all of the risk that you're monitoring how are you going to report to them all these templates have been approved already by your leadership yay so now it's time to start distributing right you've got your first re performance reporting cycle.
**Susan Daniels**: you're not nervous because you've already gotten all kinds of feedback from your sponsors you already know it needs expectations.
**Susan Daniels**: Now that you have the confidence to hit send hey this is when communications requirements analysis comes into play, they will.
**Susan Daniels**: Immediately let you know whether what you're sending out meets the stakeholders needs okay so remember that that column, I had on my communication plan for feedback.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay Well, this is where I take the email feedbacks or the text feedbacks and they say I don't need to be on this distribution list or.
**Susan Daniels**: um I heard, I would like access to this document, because they see someone else has it and they didn't get it or they'll let you know I want to know that, too, so that's fine that's fine I will over communicate about my project vs under communicate.
**Susan Daniels**: And Okay, so another way that you can, if you if you send it all out and it's kind of silent, you know you're not hearing anything back do not assume 100% success.
**Susan Daniels**: um you may want to send out a questionnaire or a survey after like the second or the third reporting cycle if you're not really getting feedback.
**Susan Daniels**: because sometimes people just move so fast and there's so much coming across their desk they don't have time to complain right they have recommendations things could be better but.
**Susan Daniels**: They don't have the time to actually you didn't ask so they're not going to tell you it's good enough right.
**Susan Daniels**: If you send out a questionnaire and saying hey are my communications relative to this project, you know meeting your expectations and then you kind of list the arm.
**Susan Daniels**: The different things you're sending them the schedule the budget, the risk the racy whatever it is you send them.
**Susan Daniels**: it's a wonderful chance for them to go well actually Susan you know are actually project manager that that that that that the da so that's the communications requirement analysis, are you giving.
**Susan Daniels**: people what they need, and what they want, in the way that they need it and the way they want it.
**Susan Daniels**: enables effective choices regarding the technologies to be recommended.
**Susan Daniels**: that's a really complicated way of saying, did you use the right communication channel okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Are these people who like email or do they like text do they like just to get an alert that it's available or do you want to they expect to have the whole report sent to them now.
**Susan Daniels**: aren't getting it in a way that meets their their technology level their sophistication and ease of use Okay, does it require a lot of customization.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, depending on who's telling you they needed differently yeah you may need to customize one off for for high influence and high power stakeholders.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, and by this communication channels, this is what that slides talking about, we have a lot of different communication channels available to us as project managers.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm not going to read them to you, but, as you can see we've got many ways that we can design our communication plan, depending on what stakeholder we're trying to reach.
**Susan Daniels**: we've come to the point in the lecture where we talk about the communication model.
**Susan Daniels**: that's a pretty busy slide.
**Susan Daniels**: So there's only a couple of things that you need to know for sure okay for sure.
**Susan Daniels**: And it's mostly vocabulary, believe it or not, I think conceptually when I walk you through it you'll have it one and done it's not that complicated so first of all we've got the sender right we've got the sender and the emotional state of the sender can impact, how they send the message.
**Susan Daniels**: Anybody heard of writing never write an angry email right always cool down first right, so their emotional state can have a lot to do with how they come across right or how they capture what they're feeling.
**Susan Daniels**: So, the key word that you need to know here is in code okay encode encode means the sender has an idea right, but they have to figure out a way to communicate that idea.
**Susan Daniels**: They encode by choosing words numbers pictures graphs songs emojis means see where i'm going with this what they have to decide how to take that idea and communicate it in coded in such a way that it can be transmitted to somebody else.
**Susan Daniels**: Once that decision has been made Okay, and again it might be influenced by a lot of factors over here in the current state, but the decision of encoding is taking information and putting it into some.
**Susan Daniels**: Symbolic representation write letters words graphs pictures info graphs charts all of these are encoding of an idea.
**Susan Daniels**: Then they have to find a way to transmit it and that's where we get back to what's the communication channel that we're going to use lots of choices right, but they have to have the idea encoded and then fix how they're going to transmit it what medium.
**Susan Daniels**: Now there's this little symbol here for noise.
**Susan Daniels**: Yes, it does mean noise, like the dogs barking in the background during zoom calls it does mean the siren going off in the background, on this Okay, but it also means not just external noise but internal noise what.
**Susan Daniels**: Internal noise when i'm talking to you all day long you're checking in and out with me.
**Susan Daniels**: I don't have your attention 100% on interrupted Lee I know that you know that you may have to think about tomorrow.
**Susan Daniels**: or think about what you're fixing for dinner or picking up your children or what the traffic might be like you have things that interrupt your concentration and ability to understand what's being transmitted that's noise.
**Susan Daniels**: Internal and external distractions.
**Susan Daniels**: But let's say is successful right the entire message gets transmitted through the receiver then has the challenge of trying to interpret understand what's been transmitted right.
**Susan Daniels**: That is the that the action of decoding.
**Susan Daniels**: So, for your exam and for your notes, be sure to know the sender encodes.
**Susan Daniels**: The receiver decodes in the first pass of the model okay so let's say they're able to decode it, and now they want to respond, then it's their turn to encode Okay, and the thing goes back and forth.
**Susan Daniels**: Before I get to this part the bottom half of it, let me pause and tell you that just because someone encode something doesn't mean the other person can decode it someone could send me beautifully written precisely stated.
**Susan Daniels**: idea in Sanskrit I would get nothing from them Okay, so I I can't always decode what is been sent, even if it's been perfectly prepared.
**Susan Daniels**: The takeaway of, that is, you have to be sure that what you're transmitting can be interpreted and understood, let me give you another example.
**Susan Daniels**: Because I think everyone's going to pick the right language, I just wanted an extreme example, let me give you something closer to home.
**Susan Daniels**: I have a 20 something year old daughter who's very much into pop culture hey and she sent me a mean, this is a graphic on off the Internet that was supposed to be funny.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, unfortunately I didn't recognize the pop culture reference and what the meme was saying, had no point of relevance in my world.
**Susan Daniels**: So this particular thought she'd make me laugh for the day right send me a giggle blew past me in both lanes I got nothing okay So although it made a lot of sense to her okay just pick your encoding method carefully.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, and if anybody has 20 something or teenage children i'm sure you understand, they talk in ways that we don't understand the jargon we don't understand the terms, and I think they do that on purpose, sometimes okay yeah okay.
**Susan Daniels**: All right, so but let's in this case, say that were successful, and we decode the concept right well our job can do we give feedback let's talk about acknowledgement and feedback there's a difference acknowledge and feedback there's a difference.
**Susan Daniels**: When you acknowledge something like a good example would be in the emails you can have a read receive all acknowledge is message received okay doesn't mean it's understood or that you agree Okay, it just says, I got it.
**Susan Daniels**: Now, unfortunately, some of us will simply acknowledge.
**Susan Daniels**: Our senders okay why saying things like huh uh huh oh.
**Susan Daniels**: OK, we aren't necessarily doing anything more than acknowledging that they're talking at us.
**Susan Daniels**: But let's say that we've decoded it, and now we want to be responsive, we want to send feed back.
**Susan Daniels**: they've they've taken into account and interpret it, and now they send it they rent you have this same risk as the risk, you know as the sender being the receiver that they may have internal or external.
**Susan Daniels**: distraction, but if they actually get the message through then their term is to decode and we start the process over again, I will pause for questions about this slide because there are some key terms here and concepts and just want to make sure we're all on the same page.
**Susan Daniels**: not seeing anything coming through the chat yet.
**Susan Daniels**: So let me talk to you about when we are picking that communication channel right.
**Susan Daniels**: We have different kinds of channels Okay, we have things that are called.
**Susan Daniels**: The knowledge and agreed.
**Susan Daniels**: Thanks give i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: So.
**Susan Daniels**: not sure jarrod what g to G means um but, but thanks Derek.
**Susan Daniels**: In your communication methods we have push pull and interactive and what we need to understand is what each one of these communication channels do for us okay and discern the differences between them.
**Susan Daniels**: push okay pushes has specificity and you know notes put a push channel is specific Okay, you have a target audience, I want you to think of emails okay were you sort of a memo that you send out to a lot of different people but it's very specific, who is sent to.
**Susan Daniels**: push can be.
**Susan Daniels**: When you you send a text to several different people at the same time, or to one person at a time you've pushed it to them hey push a specific target audience.
**Susan Daniels**: pull simply says, I am going to put it out on your location, like a blog a website folder in the cloud Okay, I have made it available for people to pull down at well okay.
**Susan Daniels**: As the as the sender I don't necessarily know who all pulled it down when great particularly blogs and websites, I might not know for sure we're getting better at tracking though but let's just say.
**Susan Daniels**: In a pool environment, the information is made available, and it gets pulled by the people, when and if they want.
**Susan Daniels**: This is great for performance reports, it is so much wiser to take your performance reports put them in a cloud location.
**Susan Daniels**: And then send a notification a targeted notification push the notification with links.
**Susan Daniels**: The performance reports for this xyz reporting cycle, are now available at the on the cloud the sharepoint site whatever you have on the team site.
**Susan Daniels**: At the following links and then you just in your communication, give them links you've not blocked up their email you've not put them in.
**Susan Daniels**: You know too large of file coming through with all the attachments all you've done is saying hey it's out there, if you want it here's how you get it.
**Susan Daniels**: very concise communication something they can save that won't take up a lot of their storage space right they can archive it where they want in their personal emails.
**Susan Daniels**: And voila people can pull out will much more efficient communication of your performance reports versus attachment attachment attachment.
**Susan Daniels**: interactive.
**Susan Daniels**: interactive is real time okay you're having to way real time communication that's what interactive is we are using an interactive channel.
**Susan Daniels**: got a question from Cindy, are we not trying to receive some feedback from Paul what a survey not be a poor communication method i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: interesting question okay.
**Susan Daniels**: When we put something out and let them pull it down at will Okay, that is just parked there you're not really looking for a response necessarily when you push you have on sort of an expectation of a response Okay, in some way.
**Susan Daniels**: What in the example of a performance reports, the responses that they go out and pull down the information that you've targeted to them, I would a survey be pushed her pole.
**Susan Daniels**: army could be two way interactive because you're really trying to exchange.
**Susan Daniels**: is put push is focused infected it's not focused information push is a targeted audience Okay, you can have very focused information sitting out in a in a pull down okay out on the site and be very focused, but your audience of who's going to get it to be very broad nonspecific.
**Susan Daniels**: interactive communication method is face to face on its back and forth you're expecting in exchange.
**Susan Daniels**: push communication is between the sender and the receiver.
**Susan Daniels**: um i'm not sure i'm agreeing with you ramsey on on that pushes to a target audience pool is available at will and interactive as you're expecting a response.
**Susan Daniels**: can interact, to be more than two way like in a group was an example of that right now, one person to hundreds okay that's interactive okay right, I agree with you Lisa like now.
**Susan Daniels**: Alright, so I need to move on and in the interest of time, let me see where I am on my.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm doing fine that's always nice um.
**Susan Daniels**: So the next thing we need to talk about is types of feedback okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Communication, for it to be effective communication is kind of on when you have feedback is two way right you're expecting something to come back when you're doing interactive.
**Susan Daniels**: Feedback can be positive and negative they use the words critical or affirming okay.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm good, the most important thing is to be effective, it needs to be clear, specific and offered in a timely manner.
**Susan Daniels**: And this has to do with feedback, particularly regarding performance right, if you want to provide feedback on someone's performance.
**Susan Daniels**: You want to do it as quickly as possible, so it is still fresh I and you're addressing something as close to real time concern as possible.
**Susan Daniels**: And feedback should be done privately on if it's critical feedback, or if it's constructive feedback critical is really not the goal constructive is.
**Susan Daniels**: um but always feel free to provide praise in a public environment right you praise in public great job so and so really appreciate the specific Okay, how you did X y&z on this report pray should be specific.
**Susan Daniels**: And in real and timely Okay, and to the extent, maybe even publicly right to let other people know.
**Susan Daniels**: here's a tip and it's not going to be in your your P amp T but.
**Susan Daniels**: When you want to praise it excellent work okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Frequently, an approach to that is to write the email to the employees direct supervisor right, particularly as a subject matter expert you've been counting on and they've done a really good job for you.
**Susan Daniels**: Will you send a message to their supervisor and let them know what an outstanding job they've done and how much you value and appreciate this person can you see see the person.
**Susan Daniels**: What that does is it gives the supervisor some an email, they can print and put in their file for the employee for that next performance review right if they're a good manager.
**Susan Daniels**: If you send it just to the employee then it's awkward for them to have to forward it to their supervisor looky what a good job, I did right it's kind of awkward and uncomfortable, but if you send it to the supervisor and copy the employee then there's her like.
**Susan Daniels**: You know they it's just to me in my experience has been i've gotten more good from that approach.
**Susan Daniels**: Is that not bad for team culture for you to praise someone and let them know they're doing a good job.
**Susan Daniels**: On there's nothing wrong with that now if i'm showing favoritism consistently on walking out to one person yes that's bad for team team morale.
**Susan Daniels**: But the team should know when somebody is really rung the bell or done a great job Okay, let them know let your team know you recognize excellence Okay, and you appreciate excellence.
**Susan Daniels**: Right navy Aaron says navy says praise and public reprimand and private, but sometimes praising in public you don't have that opportunity in real time quickly feedback, so you have to do it through other communication channels okay.
**Susan Daniels**: This is a good place for us to Well, I can cover.
**Susan Daniels**: You know this is a good place for us to take a break, because the next thing that we're going to get into is we're going to do engage stakeholders and.
well.
**Susan Daniels**: yeah let's go ahead and do that i'm going to go ahead and set it up for us to take a 15 minute break, because on what we have still to go through.
**Susan Daniels**: we'll still have time at the end of the day, to have some Q amp eggs right, but I want to not go really more than an hour or so before you guys are up moving around, and you know getting the blood circulating and just just basically.
**Susan Daniels**: Staying staying awake for me, because this is a long day and we're coming in the last lap so let's go ahead and set up the break we're going to make it a 15 minute break and I will see you shortly.